el banco yubs comprará a su rival Credit
swiss por un valor de 3.000 millones de
euros el que era considerado como el
segundo establecimiento bancario más
importante de Suiza se convertirá en una
filial la medida auspiciada por el
gobierno suizo tiene por objetivo
estabilizar los mercados
la fiscalía de Nueva York dice que su
equipo no se dejará intimidar por La
retórica del ex presidente Donald Trump
quien advirtió sin pruebas que sería
arrestado Este martes mientras los
republicanos señalan un caso
políticamente motivado figuras
demócratas dicen que nadie está por
encima de la ley
este lunes 20 de marzo se cumplen 20
años del inicio de la invasión en Irak
liderada por Estados Unidos pero fue el
19 de marzo cuando Washington comenzó a
lanzar misiles marcándola antesala de la
guerra iremos hasta Bagdad con nuestra
enviada especial
Hola Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en France 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz el gigante bancario suizo y
vs acordó comprar por más de 3000
millones de euros a su rival Credit
suicis que tuvo intensas dificultades
financieras en recientes semanas el
gobierno suizo tuvo un papel importante
en la negociación otorgando diversas
facilidades para que el banco se quedara
en manos de una empresa Suiza se espera
que la histórica compra alivia las
tensiones financieras del Credit suiz y
tranquilice los mercados europeos
el fruto de intensas negociaciones
durante el fin de semana es una compra
arriesgada del banco suizo número uno la
esperanza es evitar el caos cuando los
mercados asiáticos abran el lunes por la
mañana el gobierno suizo a mediado en el
acuerdo anunciado el domingo por la
noche
On Friday
el viernes las salidas de liquidez y la
volatilidad de los mercados demostraron
que ya no era posible restablecer la
confianza necesaria por lo que era
absolutamente necesaria una solución
rápida y estabilizadora esta solución es
la absorción de crédito twist por vs
por ello el gobierno suizo Se
comprometió a un programa de apoyo
financiero a vs en la adquisición como
incentivo para cerrar el trato otros
compradores se interesaron por algunos
de los activos del banco pero el
gobierno se hizo presionó para que se
llegara a un acuerdo con el competidor
local tras la quiebra del silicon el 10
de marzo se produjo un caso de contagio
el precio de acciones del crédito Swift
alcanzó un mínimo histórico el pasado 15
de marzo con una caída del 30% en un
solo día el Banco Nacional suizo
respondió con un préstamo de 50.000
millones de francos suizos A última hora
del miércoles pero la recuperación duró
poco y al cierre del viernes de las
acciones habían bajado un 25% respecto
al comienzo de la semana Credit suicis
se ha visto salpicado por una serie de
escándalos y fallos de cumplimiento vs
tenía claro que la nueva dirección
realizaría cambios importantes
vs tiene la intención de reducir el
negocio de banca de inversión de crédito
swiss y alinearlo con nuestra cultura de
riesgo conservador
Credit suiz es el segundo mayor banco de
Suiza y uno de los 30 bancos
considerados esenciales para la
estabilidad del sector bancario mundial
se espera que esta compra restaure la
confianza en el mercado
vamos a Estados Unidos El fiscal que
Investiga el presunto pago de Donald
Trump a una actriz porno con dineros de
la campaña de 2016 se mostró firme
frente a La retórica del mandatario y
dijo que su personal no se dejará
intimidar sus declaraciones se dieron
luego de que el expresidente advirtiera
sin pruebas que iba a ser arrestado Este
martes y convocará a manifestaciones
republicanos y demócratas discuten sobre
el caso en el terreno político lluís
Muñoz con los detalles
el expresidente Donald Trump dijo el
sábado que le iban a restar el martes
llamó a protestar y se fue a un evento
de lucha libre este domingo se conoció
un comunicado del fiscal que lleva el
caso en contra del expresidente un
mensaje dirigido a su equipo y revelado
por el medio de comunicación político
tenemos plena confianza en nuestro
destacado personal de seguridad e
investigadores junto con nuestros
excelentes colegas de la oficina
administrativa de la corte y la policía
de Nueva York y continuaremos
coordinándonos con todos ellos no
toleraremos los intentos de intimidar a
nuestra oficina o amenazar el estado de
derecho en Nueva York
Más allá de la expectativa mediática la
guerra política los republicanos se
sitúan al lado de quien Busca seguir
siendo su líder incluso su ex
vicepresidente Mike pence
esto se siente como un cargado juicio
político y yo por mi parte siento que
esto no es lo que el pueblo
estadounidense quiere ver tenemos
verdaderos desafíos en este país hoy
mientras que los demócratas ven una
oportunidad de inhabilitar a quien sería
el enemigo más temido para las
elecciones de 2024
Este es otro caso en el que Donald Trump
simplemente trata de promover los
intereses de Donald Trump no del resto
de la nación seamos claros sobre lo que
está pasando aquí nadie está por encima
de la ley ni siquiera el expresidente de
Estados Unidos
[Música]
un gran Jurado de Nueva York Investiga
los presuntos pagos de Trump durante la
campaña de 2016 para silenciar a la
actriz porno es dormils y a la modelo de
Playboy Karen McDonald por un total de
280 mil dólares pagos registrados como
gastos legales y el martes podría
convertirse en el primer expresidente en
ser acusado de un delito
el banco interamericano de desarrollo
Indicó que América Latina y el Caribe
solo crecerán solo un 1% este 2023 así
el 24 a través de su informe
macroeconómico publicado en medio de la
crisis bancaria que preocupa a varios
países Erick parrado jefe economista del
Beat reconoció que las cifras muy baja y
que incluso podría caer más si la crisis
financiera se extendiera pero ofreció un
parte de tranquilidad para la región al
asegurar que latinoamérica es solvente y
resiliente en América Latina y el Caribe
el sistema bancario ha sido parte de la
solución y no parte del problema tenemos
bancos mucho mejor capitalizados son
mucho más líquidos y las tasas de
morosidad son mucho más bajas y por lo
tanto tenemos la resiliencia para
enfrentar ese tipo de shocks en Egipto y
en presencia de oficiales de Estados
Unidos y Jordania representantes del
gobierno de Israel y de la autoridad
Palestina llegaron a un acuerdo para
intentar detener la violencia armada de
cara al mes sagrado del ravadán que
empieza este jueves sin embargo la
mayoría de palestinas entre ellas jamás
rechazan los diálogos porque acusan a
Israel de incumplirlos y usarlos de
tapadera mientras aumenta la violencia
mortal que ejerce en sus redadas en los
territorios ocupados recordemos que en
lo que va del año las fuerzas israelíes
han asesinado 86 palestinos mientras 13
israelíes ha muerto a manos de
palestinos según la agencia afp
este domingo hace exactamente 20 años
una coalición internacional liderada por
Estados Unidos comenzó a lanzar misiles
contra Irak fue la antesala de la
invasión por tierra del 20 de marzo así
empezó una guerra ilegal basada en
pruebas falsas que marcó la doctrina
securitaria y la geopolítica de estas
décadas Catalina Gómez Ángel nuestra
enviada especial a Bagdad nos informa
sobre cómo fueron las primeras horas de
este conflicto que derrocó al fallecido
Sadam husein
a mis espaldas al otro
los palacios de gobierno del ex dictador
sadampuse y también es allí ese lugar
que luego posteriormente los
estadounidenses llamarían como la zona
verde o el famoso Green son de Bagdad y
este fue uno de los primeros lugares que
empezaron a ser atacados el 19 de marzo
de hace 20 años cuando después de meses
de conversaciones discusiones ponencias
en las Naciones Unidas y argumentos de
los norteamericanos que trataban de
convencer al mundo de que hagamos ahí
tenía un programa de armas destrucción
masiva ordenaron el ataque a este país
luego tuvieron que reconocer que Estas
armas no existían pero ya estaban dentro
del país causando un terror dentro de la
población que en algún momento algún
sector nos recibió como liberadores pero
es muy rápidamente
lo señalaron de ocupantes aquí nos
cuenta la población muchos de los que se
quedaron en Bagdad los que son mayores
es que aquel día o muchos habían sacado
a sus familias de la ciudad o se
encerraron en sus casas durante semanas
los norteamericanos entraron por el sur
por la zona de basura porque allí
estaban los grandes yacimientos de
petróleo que querían asegurar y luego
fueron subiendo hasta llegar hasta aquí
hasta la capital de Bagdad y luego ya
menos de un mes después declararían el
final de la Guerra sin embargo las
consecuencias de esta invasión han se
han prolongado en el tiempo por estos 20
años los iraquíes han sufrido una guerra
tras otra guerra y esto continuó incluso
después de que los norteamericanos ya se
retiraron del país en el 2011 luego
volvieron en el 2014 por invitación del
gobierno en la guerra contra el estado
islámico pero el país sigue sufriendo
grandes consecuencias a uno y cuando la
seguridad ha mejorado y los iraquíes
especialmente en Bagdad han vuelto a
disfrutar por lo menos de lo que es la
vida pública
recuerde que mañana lunes 20 de marzo
con motivo de los 20 años del inicio de
la guerra en Irak en 24 les ofrecemos
una programación especial en la emisión
matinal de directo América de 7 a 9 de
la mañana hora de Bogotá quito y Lima
cambiamos de tema y vamos a Francia
donde siguen las protestas en medio de
la indignación que generó la aprobación
de